In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 20th, on which we commemorate, our righteous
Father, Theodore of the hair shirt.
On the 20th of the month, we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father, Theodore Drikinas.
Saint Theodore came from a wealthy and devout Constantinopolitan family, drawn from childhood
to the angelic life he became a monk in one of the monasteries of the capital, which was
later called the monastery of the Drikinas.
He gave himself to a severe askees and always wore the same hair shirt, which earned him the
nickname of Drikinas hair shirt.
His valiant battles for virtue and his perseverance and prayer allowed him to carry off the victory
against the snares of the demons, and he acquired the grace of the Holy Spirit in abundance,
so that after his death, the balm of a heavenly fragrance flowed from his tomb, and healed
a great number of those afflicted in body and soul.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.